well thanks for for coming um this is uh
coming out of some some research that
I've been doing in other areas and I got
interested in this this question about
seven or eight um about a year ago
um I'm going to give you a little
overview of of how I got into it um and
then I'm going to talk about what what
makes a sin a deadly sin for the people
that that we're looking at here give you
some background information then we'll
actually um go into looking at a few of
these that I have on that that chart for
you um and then I'll talk a little bit
how it got disseminated into the larger
medieval culture um and we can we can
take questions and you know discuss
things at any point along the way but
then we'll maybe do some uh discussion
and Q&A specifically after that and then
afterwards I have right now the screen
is blank because we've got it turned off
I have a a slideshow of um interesting
depictions of the seven deadly sins or
of their punishments things connected to
them some of them are are classic
representations starting from about the
Renaissance on some of them are very
contemporary representations that you
may have seen or you may not have seen
so um I'm I'm Gregory Sadler I I uh
teach at fatal state for another week
and a half or so and uh I'm actually
leaving and starting a new phase of my
career up north from here um I work in
philosophy and and religious studies and
one of my areas of particular interest
is vices and virtues so that's how I got
caught up in in
this um I've been doing a lot of work on
the virtues and vices associated with
anger and since anger is considered one
of the the seven deadly sins or one of
the you know eight deadly sins depending
on which list you're looking at makes
every single list sooner or later if I
if I'm researching and I'm doing a broad
enough study I'm going to get drawn in
to reading somebody's thought on this
list about anger and I saw them talking
about anger as one of the the
principal sins and in order to
understand a philosopher or a theologian
you have to look at their work as whole
you can't just um begin from one little
portion you have to read through it so
because I was looking at people like
John Cassian or Thomas aquinus or St
Bonaventure um studying anger inevitably
meant looking at this this notion of of
the seven deadly sins or the eight
deadly
sins
um what I was surprised to find out when
I first read John cassan I'd always
heard of seven deadly sins and I think
most of us probably have that that
experience too you know You' probably
seen say the movie Seven and and
probably a lot of you can rattle off the
list you know in in fairly close order
you might mix them up you know put one
in place of the other but we're all used
to thinking of seven deadly sins so when
I opened up John cassian's conferences
and his institutes and I saw that there
were eight principal faults I thought
what's going on here and then I looked
at his his listing and I said where's
eny it's not in there and what are these
other two in there how did this happen
so I became very interested in this and
it turns out there's actually a a
literature on this um many other people
have have noticed this including some of
the people were going to look at tonight
um so I started this this larger
comparative project of of looking at
treatments of the the deadly sins and I
started with Theology and philosophy
because that's that's my area and I'm
expanding that study this is this is
actually just about halfway in and I've
gotten interested in how it fits into
the the culture how it affects the
culture but also how it it filters into
literature and drama and artwork um I'm
not a art historian I'm not a English
Professor or anything like that but I
think that you can recognize some of the
same themes being treated very
interestingly almost you know in a
philosophical way in say Dante or or
Cher or perhaps in some of the the art
that we're going to look at um so what
makes a sin deadly um did any of you
remember from you know catechism or you
know any other place where you yeah what
harms yourself and
others yeah although that's that's
there's a whole bunch of sins and all of
them harm self or others in one way or
another it's not enough to make it a
deadly or a capital or or a principle
sin so there's there's got to be
something
more we tend to think of it as in terms
of the punishment or the penalty it's a
deadly sin because it's really really
bad well how come murder isn't on the
list that's pretty bad right which one
murder oh murder I mean you know if if I
was posed with the choice of somebody
lusting or murdering I would I'd say go
ahead and lust and don't murder right I
had to pick between the two or go ahead
and envy um but maybe um don't bear
false witness you know don't send
somebody to prison on false testimony or
something like that so it's not just the
it's not the penalty itself although
that's what our our culture has come to
to frame it as um originally they didn't
call them deadly sins they called them
the principal sins or the capital sins
and a lot of times they didn't actually
call them sins they called them
vies uh yeah they could lead to other
sin yeah that's there you go they not
only can lead to other sins these are
the big ones that tend to produce other
sins that's why they wanted to
concentrate on these that's why they
they picked them out um that's why they
they came up with with some sort of
listings of these so that you know they
can provide motives for other sins
sometimes um they take shape in other
sins you know if you think about wrath
or anger um the Ancients and the
medievals distinguish more than one
thing that would come out of it more
than one way of being excessively or or
wrongly
angry um these are all actually the
vices and so to to understand what these
were for the people that are writing
about them it helps to know something a
little bit about this notion of vice and
again this is a word that we we use in
our culture but we use it for what
what's what's an example of a
vice drug abuse prostitution yeah well
the vice squad stuff
right yeah um and and use abuse of drugs
is in fact something that would fit
under what they call Vice um you don't
just do it once you do it habitually
right um usually people say stuff like
smoking smoking is a vice you know and
then you can think of why is it a vice
that's a dirty
habit now you're actually getting closer
because what is a vice a vice is a habit
it's a it's a dispos position to do a
certain kind of thing so if I have a
vicious disposition with respect to
anger that means that I not only once in
a while but habitually when I'm put into
situations I get angry at people that I
shouldn't or I get too angry or too
quickly or I don't forgive when I ought
to there's a lot of different uh
possibilities for that if I have a vice
of envy that means that I don't just
Envy once in a while that's part of my
character that's part of what I do
that's part of you know Case For Better
or For Worse in this case it's for Worse
that's part of who I am so virtues and
vices are you know the good and the bad
moral character traits that we we
develop or sometimes you know we're
stuck with um so all of these
are are vices and all of them are
opposed to certain
virtues um this understanding of them
came it didn't come out of a vacuum it's
not as if the the church just showed up
and said all right we need a list of
seven bad things let's come up with them
uh what do we want to put it put a stop
to uh instead it came out of a very
different kind of
context where are these things discussed
first before uh Christianity comes on
the scene in ancient
philosophy so you have Plato and
Aristotle and stoics and many other
people talking about you know what makes
a person good what makes a person bad
well it's possession of certain virtues
or vices and then they start thinking
about how do you let's say you have vies
how do you move away from them does it
involve just gaining some knowledge does
it involve changing your habits does it
involve changing the way in which you
feel or desire or think about things um
those are the sort of things that they
they were preoccupied with and when the
first Christian writers are are on the
scene you know after the gospels after
the Epistles although Paul himself you
know had studied um and he didn't just
just study tah he knew ancient culture
um they engaged ancient philosophy so
Christian thought about this doesn't
just come say straight out of the the uh
scriptures that they had at the time it
comes out of a lot of reflection a lot
of Engagement with the culture of their
time which included philosophy
um and and philosophy was understood a
little bit different back differently
back then than it is now I belong to a a
not a department of philosophy but a
philosophy area within the department of
government and history um and if you ask
people what's philosophy they might say
something like well you know what that
guy over there
teaches you know and then you say well
what is he teaching well I don't know
let's go to the book store and look at
the books that that that he's assigning
that's
philosophy well that that's that's a
very small part of it and that's not
what the Ancients thought of as
philosophy because there wasn't any me
back then or fville state or textbooks
or anything like that what did they
think of of philosophy as being well it
was actually a way of
life uh a way of life that was was
ordered and carried out according to
certain principles that's what made it
different than say just going out and
doing what whatever you wanted um and
different philosophies began from
different sets of principles um
and they were trying to orient
themselves to what was best what they
thought was most
worthwhile
so all of the stuff about virtues and
vices fits in with that that's why they
were were studying these things they
were trying to make sense out of The
Human Experience of Good and Evil in the
world and we all we've all encountered
that we all of us are adults we've all
uh met good people we've met bad people
we can probably say why we think this
person is good why we think that one is
bad we can have arguments with each
other about whether they really are good
or bad or just perhaps misunderstood but
the fact that we can actually talk about
this and agree about this means there's
a reality that that we're studying
something that we're interested in and
they were just as interested in that uh
2,000 years ago uh as as we are today
perhaps
more um they they couldn't distract
themselves with you know smartphones and
television and things like that um
and how did they do this well they they
drew on a lot of different sources some
of it is experience you watch people you
see how they act you know you you uh you
can't actually see the inside of
somebody's Soul or their brain or their
heart or however you want to put it but
you can watch their behavior over time
you can see how they behave in certain
situations and you can start to
generalize about people on that basis um
teaching you know the these these
Christian authors they are not working
in a vacuum but neither were the ancient
philosophers they if you if you read
Plato's dialogues Plato actually has
socres saying well this other guy over
here says this he's reacting he's either
accepting or rejecting somebody else's
teaching um drama narrative the ancient
Greeks um why did they love homer so
much because he told good
stories me there are good
stories well why did they think he was
so
important we read him because he's part
of a literature class right and it's
good that we do that we don't set up our
lives according to Homer though do we
some of those Greeks were they would say
well you know you should be like
aysus or you should be like you know
this guy over here or they would take a
speech and they would say hey that's
that's got some real insight in it let's
let's make something out of this um
another thing that they were interested
in was was understanding human nature
the these are people that were really
concerned with that and that continues
through to these Christian authors um
again there's sort of a tendency to look
at them as if they're they're primarily
interested in other worldly things when
you start talking about the The Vices
and the virtues or the you know what
we're going to call here the principal
or capital
sins um you're you're really interested
human nature you're interested in two
ways how is it damaged and how ought it
to be um the the deadly sins are those
which lead us away from for these these
authors from how we ought to be what we
were made to be um and the Ancients they
had their own listings of Virtues and
vices and when Christianity comes on the
scene it brings some some new ones or or
it revalues some old ones good example
of this is
humility
um humility was not seen as a good thing
for most of the Greeks was seen as being
servile as being something less than
what you you ought to be um Aristotle
says some bad things about it what does
Christianity say about
humility good the meek shall inherit the
earth the meek shall inherit the earth
although actually Meek is is something
different um what we translate as Meek
um well it is connected what we
translate as Meek is the Greek word that
in in say Aristotle's text is translated
as good tempered or mild prow and and
meekness or or or or mildness has to do
with
anger meekness means not losing your
temper having a good disposition being
able to put up with other people's
things without getting excessively angry
at them which is a natural human thing
to do right do most of us a on the side
of getting too angry or not angry
enough well most of us though we we can
air both but um you know if we look at
our experience yeah and so the Meek um
that that that same Greek word is being
used for all these things and we don't
realize it because we translate it
differently in the gospels than we do in
say
Aristotle um Moses is also called Meek
prow and think about it Moses is a guy
who put people to
death um but he he behaved in in he he
didn't do it because he was trying to
get revenge or or anything like that
um meekness is not exactly the same
thing as as as humility but it it it
it's tied in with it it's tied in with
patience it's tied in with these other
virtues that that Christianity comes on
the scene and says yeah you guys were
you guys are mixed up about this here's
here's a better way to live um so
Christianity doesn't just wipe all this
context away it takes it and integrates
it as best as it can are there still
some tensions there probably
um and and you know we could talk more
about that now there's a couple
different ways of understanding these
deadly sins or these capital sins and
these tie in with what the these people
were were trying to do um why were they
so Keen to identify these these vices or
these complexes of behavior and thinking
and desires um well it could be they
just wanted to control people right they
just wanted to set a stamp down and say
thou shalt
not um and and there always have been
people who would use these lists in in
such ways and we're going to talk about
a time where that became more more
prevalent um but if you actually look at
the the people that I've got in that
chart and the people we're going to look
at tonight what were they about what
were they writing these these books for
they were trying to help people in the
path towards um spiritual life they they
most of them at the start are monks out
in the desert they're not writing for
Lay people they're writing for how the
monk the person who is really really
serious about this this whole Christian
idea and wants to go off and leave
things behind what should they be
focusing on what sort of what sort of
dangers and challenges are they going to
face what do they have to know about
themselves in order to not fall prey to
to things later on something a bit
different gets gets done done with it um
you know later on it's to assist those
who are preaching or doing spiritual
direction or particularly confession
we'll we'll talk about that in a little
while um so one of the first people that
that we get something like this with is
this guy
cyprian um he's in the third century and
a lot of people had
um you know mentions of different sins
actually if you look at Paul's letters
he'll w off don't do this don't do this
don't do this you know whole lists of of
of sins but nobody had sort of codified
them and tried to think out you know
their connections with each other
cyprien is starting to to do that
cyprian also notes something kind of
interesting which is when we knock down
one of the big ones one of the ones that
we've really been struggling with what
what happens next do you think
everything you know the an Heaven's open
up and the Angels Sing and it's all
happy ever
after
you got
6 there you go yeah when when you knock
down one Vice others start to to assert
themselves more more uh they they start
to make their claims more strongly the
next guy is on your your chart it's this
uh evagrius Pontius who's in the fourth
Century he's a he's a monk and he's out
in the desert and he is coming up with
um a listing of the what he calls the
the not the principal vices or or sins
but the the main thoughts that are going
to be suggested and he he thinks they're
going to be suggested by not just our
own nature but by by the agency of
demons uh who want to screw us up who
want to trip us up who want to they
can't make us do anything but they can
they can keep bothering us with things
that they they know will push our
buttons until we we decide to give into
them and so he talks about eight
different generic tempting thoughts um
and he says that these contain within
themselves all the other ones so this
goes to they they tend to bring about
other vices one of them is gluttony um
the pleasures of uh you know eating
drinking the desires for that to an
excessive amount then there's uh
something that we can translate it's
translated a lot of ways fornication
lost um
um uh there's a lot of sort of e
euphemistic ways of of rendering it but
it's basically lost you know sexual
sexual desire that is oriented um in the
wrong ways and that it it it uh wants to
satisfy itself too much too often with
the wrong objects that sort of thing um
covetousness or greed often we we uh see
the literature calling it covetousness
because the King James version use used
that uh another word for it is avarice
uh the Greek word itself literally means
love of money but it it can mean wealth
in general love of of material
possessions that's what greed is uh then
anger
um this is kind of a tricky one does
that mean that you can't can't ever be
angry at all that's what some of these
guys thought like John Cassie for
example thought it's never good to be
angry um not all the people that you're
going to look at on that chart thought
it was never good to be angry Thomas
aquinus saw legitimate Place here's
where it got really interesting so this
is eight principal
vices um this isn't the the list of the
seven deadly sins the seven deadly sins
does not have sadness on it or dejection
or there's other ways of describing this
um we tend to look at that
as not involved with that at all that
that's that's a feeling we have but
again think about why are these
problematic well because they lead to
either doing things that we shouldn't do
or not doing the things that we ought to
be doing if we're chronically
depressed are we likely to do the things
that we we ought to do probably
not um and you know this could lead to
an inter in conversation about you know
what roles do we have in in depression
if we're facing it and there are clearly
some people you know in our time that we
would say oh there you know it's a
chemical problem but there's other
therapies some of the most successful
ones like cognitive behavior therapy
they incorporate the insights of these
ancient philosophers or
theologians and they they say that you
actually have some role you have some
some agency in how you feel and AAS
would say that as well um then there's
something else that is hard to translate
um and they used the Greek term for it
they just turned it into a Latin term uh
aadi um or aadia and it means something
like uh it's something fairly similar to
this this sadness or or dejection
heaviness or weariness of heart uh the
way it's described it seems to be a kind
of being distracted with things this is
the one that's going to turn later on
into
sloth the when when Thomas gets a hold
of it then there's something called
kenoia which means
um literally empty appearance or vain
Glory we call it and boasting gets gets
placed into this and then finally the
worst one
Pride right and um from here we go to
John
Cassian Cassian takes vas's list and
he's a Latin uh Westerner he's a little
bit later in the fourth to fifth century
he goes off to the East and he studies
with these monks he wants to learn their
way of of life um there aren't a lot of
monasteries in the west at that time so
he goes first to Syria and Jerusalem and
then he goes down to Egypt where they're
stricter and he uh lives with them for
many years and he talks with them for
many years actually has a friend who
goes with him and then they go all the
way back to Marseilles and when people
make him write a book he writes a book
about it um but he doesn't he doesn't do
it until they they bother him enough to
do it and these are called his
institutes and then his conferences his
conferences are actually narrations of
conversations that he had with these
Abbotts way out in the The Boonies in
the middle of nowhere and the institutes
are his sort of trying to figure this
stuff stuff out himself and and
systematizing and he has the same basic
eight schema as evagrius does but he
tells us some more interesting things
about this he says that gluttony is the
first one that we have to address and
that if you don't address gluty and
again he's talking to monks if you don't
address if you don't address glot if you
don't get the urges of the body under
control you're going to have a really
hard time with all of the rest of them
um and then you know uh lust comes after
that you start working on that and you
know we we often think of these these
religious people as almost um inhuman
you know as if they don't have sexual
urges if you read this monastic
literature these guys were really
struggling with that stuff all the time
you know sometimes even even when they
are
old um covetousness uh this is this is
one that um leads to a lot of different
things he says leads to lying to deceit
to false witness um I looked at Cassian
a lot on anger and I talked about that a
several months ago here in a different
talk U Cassian took a very very strict
stance on anger he said that we should
we should never be angry except with
ourselves um any any other case of being
angry is is culpable it's leading to
problems and this is an interesting case
because there are certain scriptural
passages that talk about anger and some
theologians interpreted them to say for
instance um you know you shouldn't be
angry with your brother unless you have
good cause Cassian says no way there's
never good cause so he's he's really a
hardliner about this um dejection he
gives us a bit more description about
this that that helps us understand it um
it makes us unhospitable
uh it makes us unwilling to engage in in
projects to be with other people does
this sound a little bit more like like
uh
depression yeah it can also make us
despare about about salvation and then
we just say screw it I'm not going to do
anything I'm going to do whatever I want
and you notice that's a tendency that
that would then produce other problems
wouldn't it um he also talks about um
aadia and he says this is a weakness or
distress of heart this is also the
Noonday devil that gets mentioned in the
in the Psalms and he talks about it as a
sort of there's two different ways he
talks about it one is a sort
of
dissatisfaction with oneself and one's
spiritual progress and everything that's
going on with oneself and and not
sticking to your work not putting
yourself in your work finding fault with
it um
it's it Al so it produces a kind of
laziness this is why it's going to lead
ultimately to sloth he also talks about
and I guess this must have been a real
problem for these monks he talks
about being distracted not not settling
down and doing things so what these
monks would do here's here's what he
actually singles out they would say I
think I shouldn't work on this stuff
today I should go see how brother so and
so is
doing I should go I should go check up
on him and then they go and check up on
him and they're not feeling any better
because they didn't address what was
going on inside them uh and now the
work's not done either and now they
there there's sort of this cycle to it
and now they come back and then they
think I really got to settle down and
get get this done don't
I but you know there's something else
going on over there I should go check
out
too anybody who's had to get something
done at the last minute because they
procrastinated has gone through
aadia
um Vin Glory um Cassian tells us
something really interesting about vain
Glory he says that
um the other Vice is you know they're
pretty
straightforward they they they attack
you and if if they get you down they
kick you he doesn't say it quite like
that you know we can that's part of our
parlot vain Glory arises when you're
doing pretty good
good so if you master your anger or you
master your
sloth then what's the next tendency man
I'm doing pretty good I'm a really
spiritual person I'm a lot more
spiritual than that guy over there I
should probably be Abbot I should be
giving people you know lectures about
how one ought to be living the spiritual
life I ought to be preaching he talks
about like this um that's that's Vin
Glory thinking too much of of oneself uh
and then finally something that's very
close to it is is pride and pride
actually you know we don't have Envy in
this list where does Envy come in Pride
produces
Envy um because what is pride pride is
thinking that one self is um greater is
better than than other people it's
something a little bit different than
than vain glory and cassan says
something really interesting about this
he says with each of these other vices
they're they're opposed to some other
virtue a virtue is a way that we ought
to be so think about meekness right uh
we ought to be meek that means that we
shouldn't get angry we shouldn't you
know somebody uh Cuts you off you
shouldn't give them the the the finger
um you should control your anger and
eventually you should learn how to
forgive fairly quickly um so there
there's a there's a vice and there's an
opposed virtue right um gluttony what
would be what would be opposed to that
do you think um we don't actually use
the word Much
Anymore fasting fasting is how you beat
it um but fasting is not an end in
itself and cassine actually writes about
these people who fast too much for the
wrong reason he says that's no good
either
um but what could fasting be part of
because you're on the right track cing
what's that spiritual cleansing the body
well the the body and and the the soul
are connected for for these guys um see
we don't actually use the word much
moderation Temperance that that's the
virtue of taking the amount that we
actually need and and and not
more um you know it why do we eat more
than than we we need to because eating
is so much fun and tastes so good and
you know it satisfies a natural need but
then there's so many wonderful tasting
things out there that you you know we
can eat all day long and drink all day
long and you know people have done that
sort of thing
so if if you're if you're um a gloton
you don't have the virtue of moderation
it's been destroyed in you if you're
wrathful you don't have the virtue of
meekness right or nence or however you
want be patience um Pride Cassie says is
not like that Pride destroys all of the
virtues it's it's sort of like the Adam
Bomb of
vies
um and he says it's not opposed to a
virtue or to an angel that that that's
supposed to help us with that virtue
it's opposed to God
himself because what is pride
ultimately you can think of pride in
terms of other people right if I'm
prideful I'm better than all of you
whether I really am or not in my mind
I'm better than all of you and so I
should get more stuff than all of you
whether it's you know money attention
food I should get better stuff than all
of you too and when we have
conversations I should get to talk you
should get to listen you know it goes on
and on right I like this
um well why now put it in a Christian
context so there there's a you know
Transcendent God who created all of us
if I take that sort of position and I
say I am so worthwhile everything I've
got that's good you know is mine came
from me um I'm I'm placing myself above
god um uh because you know rightly
understood none of that good stuff came
really from me uh where did it come from
whatever whatever qualities I may have
that are
good in a Christian context came from
God I may have you know done some
polishing and you know fixing them up
but I didn't create you know my being I
didn't create where I wound up I didn't
create the opportunities that I was
given um so Pride is very is very
dangerous
umran cont is original
yes well that's that's interesting it's
the original sin for human beings but
it's not the original sin right because
before the fall of Adam and Eve there's
another fall that takes place Luci right
and now Lucifer is an angel so he's not
going to fall through gluttony or lost
or or anything because he doesn't have a
body he's a pure purely according you
know to this this this stuff he a purely
spiritual being and what good didn't he
possess what could possibly have been
his incentive for for you know with as
much knowledge as he has saying screw
you to to to God I'm gonna do things my
way Pride it's the only it's the only
answer and so to be engaged in that is a
way to be
luciferian um and again you know common
common sin and it is for um Cassian and
for the rest of these these people it is
the one which the other ones come out of
ultimately why do we why do we um do any
of these things pride is at the root of
that
um let me go on then
to
ums true
uh I should have done this here go uh
Gregory the
Great
um I don't know how many gregories there
there actually were that were
theologians I know there I think I think
there were unless I'm mistaken this
there's either TW there's 12 popes right
that were gregory no I don't know was it
16 cathic history yeah but there are a
lot of other theologians named Gregory
this is the only one who gets called the
great um so he's easy to keep track of
and he's a benedic and monk um and he
actually writes a life of St Benedict uh
when when he's got some free time as a
matter of fact he didn't like being pop
he didn't he didn't like being Bishop he
didn't like being anything whenever they
gave him an opportunity he would run
away and and try to get back to the
monastery and they would make it they
they like forced him to be Pope the poor
guy um now he writes this book called
moral moralia in Joel and it's a book of
scriptural
interpretation um back then they had
this notion that scripture has a number
of different senses a number of
different ways that you can read it and
one of these is the moral sense what is
scripture telling how is scripture
telling us we ought to behave we ought
to be and so he's reading the book of
Job and trying to draw all the possible
moral lessons from it and this was a
very popular book in the Middle Ages as
was John cassian's um conferences and
institutes and there's one chapter in
there where he talks about the the
principle sins and this is one where we
start to see the transition from 8 to
seven he doesn't actually say that
there's only seven per se and that
that's it he actually treats eight of
them but what does he do he takes pride
and he says pride is the fountain that
all the other ones flow from he doesn't
call Pride one of the principal sins or
capital sins he names the other seven
and this is where that listing later on
comes from he also changes it a little
bit most of the one most of the sins
that are there are the same as John
Cassian or AAS have um
but um Envy is added Envy is picked out
now as something to focus on whereas
John cassing didn't didn't do that uh
and Acadia is more or less rolled into
sadness they're not yet calling it sloth
at this point they're they're looking at
it under the rubric of sort of being
dejected of of of sadness of of
gloominess is another way it gets
translated and he talks about um a
progression of of five different of of
these vices coming right from pride
pride leads to Vain Glory because if you
place yourself above everything else
you're going to have an overly high
opinion of yourself aren't you right and
if you have if you are vain
glorious then you are going to be
envious too aren't you because what what
is the reality that you experience if
you think you're better than everybody
else does everybody else treat you that
way they give prizes to all sorts of
other people that should be your prize
right nobody else should be getting the
gold
star because nobody else deserves it
then you'll become envious and then what
what do you think is going to follow
from
that if you have to pick another one of
these principal
devices Ang good exactly
exactly because you
know you really have a good reason to be
angry don't
you now when you get
angry what's going to happen after that
what it's this is kind of interesting
they had a lot of insight into human
nature you've all been angry you've all
all lost your temper right I'm going to
assume that um how do you feel
afterwards when you're no longer
angry sad yeah
why
you you you sad because you you were
angry you could be sad because you lost
your temper lost your temp you meant not
to do it anymore and you're lamenting
your your poor spiritual state or how
how little progress you've made I know
I've felt that um what else though what
else might you be say tired what's that
tired yeah when when you get into a
knockdown drag drag out argument with
somebody that goes on for hours and
hours uh when you're done you are you
are just wiped out you're not ready to
work and you're not ready to to do the
things that you ought to be doing what
else what do you do when you're angry
that might make you sad
later you do things you regret you say
bad things
to yeah so sometimes the the the sadness
or dejection comes over the effects of
one one's own
anger now you know if you don't have
anger problems if you've got a really
well-tempered temper then um you won't
have that sort of thing happen
but you know a lot of us can can uh
relate to that feel kind of empty after
empty yeah because suddenly and
sometimes drive us given up or something
yeah well you know when you're angry and
this is one reason why anger can become
actually addictive you have a purpose
yeah you know you know exactly what
you're going to do as a matter of fact
you are you know focused on this one
thing how you are right and that person
is wrong and how everyone else should
know it and they have to pay and and you
know goes on and on you have you have a
motivation yeah when when you take that
away um sometimes people do feel empty
they feel sort of resourceless as if
they've got nowhere to go now when you
feel that sort
of
disappointment um especially if it has
to do with yourself and the the goods
that you thought that you
had you want to feel good
if you're not going to get it from
inside yourself where are you going to
get
it let me not yet although Al you're
right that that's that's another Gregory
doesn't talk about that it's kind of
interesting because
um in our in our society we do have
people who you know their their response
to conflict is to go go eat or their
response to depression is to go eat um I
don't think that that Gregory saw that
as as an issue he he saw the thing that
you're going have to worry about is uh
greed covetousness people try to fill in
that Gap with all sorts of external
things and you know can you ever do it
will will it ever be satisfied no so
your your greed can't actually be
satisfied these are all he says
spiritual um vices and they they come
ultimately from Pride it's it's kind of
interesting he doesn't talk about
gluttony coming from that um and he
considers gluttony and lust to be
different they're they're more bodily
more carnal VI they come from our our
natural tendencies um and he thinks this
is a little quain um that if you indulge
gluttony then you will inevitably end up
being
lustful and you know we could maybe see
this as you know these guys fasted a lot
and what happens when you fast you know
a lot of your your body's uh things
start to to shut down and to be a little
bit more manageable um and they didn't
have a high calorie diet anyway I this
he's writing at the beginning of the
Dark Ages um when when Winters are
getting longer it's actually a cooling
period in in the Earth's history as well
as a terrible time for for culture
um he says well you know if you satisfy
the
belly um the parts that are affected by
lust are actually so so close by that
they're going to be affected too and
then they're you have problems there
which strikes me as a little bit um
implausible but who knows you know maybe
this was based on something now he
thinks he talks about all of these with
a metaphor he says that because this
passage in job is actually
um it's the exhortation of the captains
and the howling of the army that's the
passage that he's reading this into so
who are the captains the captains are
the principal
vices the seven who who's where's Pride
then pride is the
queen so one of the eight vices has now
become something different and now you
have seven vices and what's the Army
then all the other things that come from
this all the other
vices that that come out of the the
seven
um now I want to give you a little
contrast here that's why I have St anel
did everyone then immediately jump and
say aha seven places we we finally
figured it out um that's the that's the
thing that makes the most sense it has
to be that way St anom didn't St anom
went with a lot of the same ideas but he
construed them in a different way um and
he read John Cassian and he read Gregory
the Great as a matter of fact ansom
mentions very few texts by name we know
that he read a lot but he doesn't tell
us a lot about what he read moralia and
job is one of the few texts that he
mentions by name and it's precisely
because all the other monasteries want
to borrow their copy so we know that
he's got a copy and that he read it and
that he had a copy what does Ansel say
he says Pride yeah pride is the Fountain
of all the sins and he actually does a
lot of analysis of Pride he talks about
it in terms of uh what he calls propria
volas which means sort of something like
an autonomous your own will as opposed
to others wills and the will of God
privileging your will above everybody
else else's um that's what he thought
the devil's first sin was was
appropriate volun us so Pride begins it
and then Pride instead of flowing into
seven uh rivers or whatever you want it
flows into three and he's got a
different listing he's got these things
like you know
curiosity um and then
um he's got another word that is very
difficult to translate well because we
don't want to translate it just as en
enjoyment period because he thought some
enjoyments were were were legitimate but
maybe illegitimate enjoyments or too
much enjoyments
Delio and then uh exelo that that's a
word and again I'm having a really hard
time translating this and I'm I'm trying
to translate the work that he actually
takes us from so it's not like I can
rely on somebody else's it means to lift
to be lifted up but it means to be
lifted up above other people or in a
wrong way or higher than you should and
um exal Tao
includes the um spiritual vices so it
includes anger it includes Envy it
includes uh vain Glory it includes uh
greed or covetousness and it includes um
sadness or or or dejection
Delio includes those two other ones glot
and
lust so he did something quite different
he he didn't get har he didn't get drawn
into the it's got to be seven thing he
was trying to think it out in a
different way and you know St anom is
not some sort of uh
slouch according to the the medievals he
was one of the guys who you know
thoroughly investigated The Vices and
the virtues but he went a very different
path than the the uh other people that
we're going to look at and here's where
we now take sort of a turn St ansam was
in the 12th
century right after the Norman Conquest
um in the 13th century something new
happens there is What's called the ladin
council and in this Council the the
Roman Church gets together and one of
the things that they decided is we
really need to place a lot more stress
on the sacrament of
confession and you know up until that
time it had been done but it had not
been done in such a systematic codified
way and there was not so much stress on
getting that
right and now the seven deadly sins
become condensed and sort of
codified because if you want to make
sure that everybody's on the same page
as far as what counts as a sin it's
really useful to have some sort of
almost like a checklist isn't
it something that everybody can agree on
Seven's an easy number to
remember so what we see happen at this
time is a lot of different manuals
coming out for
confessors for uh spiritual directors
having to do with these seven sins and
they're coming about mainly from the two
orders that are really tied in with this
the new Franciscan order and the new
Dominican order these mendicant orders
of Friars who you know they sort of take
the ball from the older orders like the
Benedicts who are still around but
aren't doing much you know new and these
other orders come on the scene and
they're very
Dynamic and a lot of the great thinkers
from that point on are not from the
Benedicts they're from these newer
orders um I'll give you just a few
examples there's this guy uh Raymond of
penor he writes what's called a Suma
it's supposed to be like a comprehensive
document that would cover all the
different cases and he does this for
penitential cases let's say somebody
comes to you for confession and they
have this sort of sin on their on their
their conscience and they committed it
in these sort of circumstances what what
kind of penance should you give them and
how bad of a sin is it that's what what
they call the case back then so he
writes a summa and he organizes it how
according to the seven deadly
sins not the eight but now it's it's
become the
seven um another guy another Dominican
William perra he writes a Suma on the
virtues and vices and he comes up with
41 different vices and then he ties them
all in with the different deadly
sins um now there's there's two those
are kind of low order thinkers or not
not I don't want to knock them but
they're not High Caliber you know people
that we we really put a lot of effort
into studying today St Bonaventure and
St Thomas of coinus they are these are
two guys who also write about these
these these sins